10 compromisos propuso gustavo petro
para su gobierno el día de su
proclamación en su primer día como
presidente se puso en marcha con dos de
ellos la consecución de la paz y hacer
de colombia un estado social de derecho
para el primero se reunió con su
homólogo chileno el también progresista
gabriel boric que es lo que hay en
concreto el deseo de continuar los
procesos iniciados en el gobierno
santos
y enriquecerlos esto incluye ahondar en
la paz con la extinta guerrilla de las
farc retomar la negociación con el
ejército de liberación nacional diálogos
suspendidos durante el gobierno de iván
duque y de los que chile seguirá siendo
garante y dialogar con el clan del golfo
para el segundo de los puntos el nuevo
ministro de economía anunció una nueva
reforma tributaria uno de los puntos más
controvertidos y esperados dado que la
presentada por el anterior gobierno dio
lugar a protestas masivas y decenas de
muertos a manos de la policía el nuevo
proyecto contempla recaudar 25 billones
de pesos durante el primer año
aproximadamente 5 mil 700 millones de
dólares la meta será recaudar 50
millones anuales combatiendo a la
evasión fiscal
esto deberá resultar en el 172 por
ciento del pib en 2023 un promedio del 1
39 por ciento entre 2024 y 2030 y 3 cómo
se conseguirá esta recaudación son cinco
los puntos claves de la propuesta del
nuevo gobierno se limitarán beneficios
tributarios a quienes ganen más de 10
millones de pesos
habrá un impuesto de patrimonio por más
de 3 mil millones de pesos mayor control
de la evasión fiscal por la que se
pierden entre 50 y 80 billones al año
impuestos a emisiones de carbono y de
salud pública impuestos del 10% a
exportaciones de carbón petróleo por
encima de los 48 dólares el barril y de
oro por encima de los 400 dólares la
onza con todo ello el gobierno espera
reducir la pobreza en cuatro puntos
porcentuales el texto deberá pasar ahora
por el congreso donde el gobierno
entrante goza de mayoría